[Aplausos]
eu descobri que eu gostava de poesia que
escrevia poesia os oito anos de idade e
aquilo ali pra mim foi uma descoberta
realmente interna
eu escrevi pra mim não contava pra
ninguém mas me fazia bem
eu descobri que a poesia uma válvula de
escape e ela me servia como se estivesse
aberto um universo paralelo pra mim ela
funcionava muito bem
eu fui conhecer um primeiro sarau aos 18
anos
até então eu praticamente não contava
pra ninguém que eu escrevi eu achava que
o que eu falava no interessados outras
pessoas que a minha trajetória não ser
importante para outras pessoas
até conhecer o sarau na periferia até
encontrar irmãos e irmãos que tinham as
mesmas inquietações que a minha
até perceber que eu podia trocar com as
pessoas o que elas falavam pra mim me
fortalecia o que eu falava pra elas
também servia de fortaleza
eu este ano no completar 28 anos de
idade e há dez anos eu tô nessa
caminhada literária independente
há quatro anos eu formei junto com
amigos e amigas um coletivo chamado
poetas ambulantes ea nossa intenção é de
clamar e distribui as poesias dentro dos
transportes públicos da cidade
mas vocês ganham dinheiro pra fazer isso
não a gente ganha um sorriso
a gente ganha atenção a gente desperta a
poesia que tem dentro das pessoas e que
elas esquecem que faz parte do nosso dia
a dia
eu já consegui lançar um livro
independente em 2013 e esse ano em março
lancei meu segundo livro também de forma
independente
engraçado quanto mais independente a
gente é mas a gente depende dos outros
mas tem sido bonito isso é importante
ver que as pessoas não for no portal é
sim e como esses movimentos eles criam
conexões
eu jamais imaginar que depois eu poderia
me levar tão longe que a poesia poderia
me levar
lippi que a poesia poderia me trazer
aqui no ano passado participei de um
evento feminista chamado diversas em bh
que a gente fez um encontro com mulheres
que estavam fazendo uma ocupação rural
a gente foi lá naquele chão de terra
batida eo encontrar as mulheres seus
filhos e uma das coisas que eu mais ouvi
nesse encontro foi quando às vezes elas
pensaram em desistir e aquilo ficou
acumulando dentro de mim e eu não
consegui entender por que mulheres com
histórias tão maravilhosa assim de
dificuldade mas por que existir mas não
sabia o quanto estavam sendo importantes
pra mim uma menina ouvir a história
delas e eu saí de lá com aquilo
reverberando dentro de mim inscrever
essa poesia não desiste negra não
desiste ainda que tentem ficar lá por
mais que queiram esconder corre em suas
veias por si ou baixe para que possa
prosseguir
eles precisam saber que a mulher negra
que é casa pra morar água para beber e
terra para se alimentar que a mulher
negra ancestralidade dgidc atabaques que
ressoam dos pés que a mulher negra tem
suas convicções suas imperfeições como
toda mulher que eu vejo que nós negras
meninas temos olhos de estrelas que por
vezes se permitem constelação
o problema é que desde sempre nos tirar
a nobreza duvidaram das nossas ciências
e que antes atendia pelo pronome alteza
hoje travar lutas diárias por sua
sobrevivência
é preciso lembrar de nossa raiz semente
negra de força matriz que brota em riste
mãos calejadas corpus marcado sim mas de
quem ainda resiste e não desiste negra
não desiste mantém a sua fé onde lhe
couber seja espírita budista do
candomblé é teu desejo de mudança magia
que traz na tua dança que vai manter de
pé a você mulher negra cujo tratamento
majestade é digna livre que arma seus
crespos contra o sistema livre para
andar na rua sem sofrer violência e que
se preciso for levantar mas sim mas
antes antes luta com um poema
que não desiste negra não desiste por
mais que tente imprimir e acredite eles
não vão parar tão cedo quanto mais você
se omitir - sobre a sua história está
escrevendo
quando olhar para as suas irmãs veja que
todas somos o início
mulheres negras desde os primórdios
desde os princípios áfrica mãe de todas
repare nos seus traços indícios é do teu
colo onde tudo principia somos as
verdadeiras da mudança de um novo ciclo
e é por isso que eu digo que não desisto
que não desisto que não desistam
resistência sempre mans gratidão